there are a lot of very prominent
scientists Richard Wrangham an
anthropologist at at Harvard is is one
who have made the case that war is
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of years old Wrangham is somebody who
studies chimpanzees and he's found
examples of chimpanzees forming groups
and raiding other chimpanzee troops and
killing one or two members of the other
troop so based on that evidence and also
the evidence that you see among some
simple pre-state tribal societies who
also engage in lethal warfare from that
Wrangham makes the case that our
ancestors have been fighting forever
basically the problem is first of all
that there are very few cases of lethal
chimpanzee fighting on average if a
scientist watches a troop for seven
years you may see one case of this sort
of fighting there's some anthropologists
who think that these lethal raids are
stemming from human encroachment on
chimpanzee have habitat it might
actually be a recent cultural behavior
among chimpanzees another problem with
the idea that war is really ancient is
that we only have good evidence of
fighting among humans going back about
ten or twelve thousand years so yes the
simplest human societies nomadic
hunter-gatherers do fight that's
clear-cut it had been thought once that
war only emerged with more complex
societies now we know the simplest
societies do fight but they only really
started fighting as I said about ten to
twelve thousand years ago there are
there is evidence of settlements and of
fairly complex societies before that
with no evidence of warfare so I think
it's really important for people to know
this basic fact that war is actually
quite a recent
behavior one of the reasons that people
tell me we will always fight Wars is
because it's in our nature it's an eight
male aggression to fight and so forth I
think that's easily refuted just because
war is so recent and there's this
enormous variability between cultures so
the second most common reason that
people cite for warfare being a
permanent part of the human condition is
that there are always too many people
for the available resources and so you
inevitably get this kind of Malthusian
situation where people are struggling
over land or or water or oil these sorts
of things the problem is is that if you
do a statistical analysis and you look
at armed conflicts through history there
are some conflicts where clearly there
was a struggle
over resources economics played a very
important role but there are other there
are other wars that didn't show resource
scarcity is a really important factor
World War one is a really good example
World War one was fought by the the
wealthiest most powerful states in the
world and it really had to do more with
national pride and these kinds of
nationalistic cultural factors than the
simple struggle over resources also the
the theory that resource scarcity leads
to war is contradicted by studies of
some simple societies there's a tribal
society in the Amazon called the
yanomamö
it's very well known it was discovered
by a and first studied by a an
anthropologist named Napoleon Chagnon
beginning in the 1960s and Chagnon wrote
this book that became a huge bestseller
called the violent people that was
published in the late 60s right during
the Vietnam War and the yanomamö fight
constantly and viciously you had these
little villages that go out and raiding
parties and and spear spear each other
and shoot arrows at each
and then raced back to their villages
and of course that leads to a feud
what Chagnon has found is that there was
an inverse correlation between the
population density because the Yanam
Yanomami are spread over a very wide
region of the amazon so he has gone to
different places and found that the more
densely populated these tribal people
are and the less food they have
available the less war there is so it's
exactly the opposite of what you'd
expect the really sparsely populated
regions where there's plenty of game to
go around those according to Chagnon
tend to be the most violent regions so
Chagnon thinks that if anything it's
because the more protein you have the
more well-fed you are the more energy
you have for this kind of sport that the
automata will see warfare as and the
more they're struggling just to feed
themselves the the the less energy they
have for warfare